c'était un ehpad c'est en passe de
devenir un hôtel restaurant cinq étoiles
et les travaux se poursuivent à
villebois mareuil à blois pour
accueillir le futur ensemble fleurs de
loire un établissement que le chef
étoilé christophe est aura la charge de
faire briller
l'ouverture est prévue en juin prochain
le point avec tristan rickli un édifice
de 5000 mètres carrés face au dernier
fleuve sauvage d'europe c'est dans ce
cadre idyllique que prend pied fleurs de
loire porté par christophe est associé à
yves en somme est un projet à 22
millions d'euros avec un hôtel deux
restaurants un spa une pâtisserie une
épicerie et un bar laventure d'une vie
pour ce chef renommé qui conserve son
identité l'écologie et les produits
locaux on a essentiellement des
entreprises locales des entreprises qui
se donnent la peine qu'ils sont
volontaires qu'ils ont qui ont envie de
bien faire on va signer un contrat avec
une société d'énergie pour l'énergie
verte et notamment de l'énergie éolienne
on va trier nos déchets on va récupérer
l'eau de pluie pour arroser toute la
partie du parc côté recrutement plus de
80 postes sont à pourvoir le restaurant
doublement étoilé de montlivault la
maison d'à côté déménagera ici pour
renaître sous un nouveau nom le
restaurant christophe est du coup quand
on va déménager
vers fleurs de loire bien entendu on
rouvrira avec avec zéro étoile est la
première chose que j'ai fait quand quand
voilà j'ai pris cette décision de
déménager c'est être prévenir les guides
qu'on aura normalement et encore une
fois je ne maîtrise pas tout ces deux
étoiles qui vont être encore dans le
guide michelin
2022 dont qui sortira en mars cette
année exceptionnellement aidant lieu
dans le petit commentaire il y aura à
noter que
en juin on sera on sera à blois et vers
ce projet fleurs de loi pour l'heure les
travaux battent leur plein fleurs de
loire devrait ouvrir ses portes au
public le 13 juin prochain une date
symbolique choisie par le chef étoilé
qui fêtera ses 45 ans ce jour là